how does a filmmaker state proactive
this business and not passive well glad
you asked I've always been proactive I
learned a long time ago to take your own
initiative don't wait for anyone to give
you anything go out there and get it
make your own opportunities I've learned
that if you're not moving forward in
this business you're moving backward you
have to stay on it after all these years
and I've got features going on
everything I still every day literally
just about every day I'm doing something
that further that new ideas new concepts
new networking new contacts whatever
whatever it is every day I have to stay
on it in terms of how to stay proactive
whatever it is if you're a writer keep
writing keep pitching and keep entering
more festivals enter your script into
coverage learn from the notes that you
get from these people I mean just stay
on your craft directing is the same
thing doing these short films keep
working on your demo reel keep working
to get your features together there's a
lot of it sometimes crosses over keep
going to market go to AFM pitch new
material go to whatever festivals or
markets you can afford I mean you know
whatever is your specialty whether it's
writing or directing stay on it every
day I have kids I'm a very busy guy I
find the time even if it's late at night
the last couple of scripts that I've
written that I sold I literally wrote
overnight that's the only time I had why
don't you do what you got to do
overnight overnight and and I've been
doing that for years and and it's fine
it's not a big deal but the point is is
you just do what you gotta do you stay
proactive if I'm not writing I'm
reaching out to people I spoke with
three high-level executives today
responded to my introduction it's just
what you do
I think certainly in this business it's
all too easy to go I'm tired I just
to this week I've got two side jobs you
know I'm just tired I'll get to my
script next week that week becomes a
month that becomes a year pretty soon
you're like I've been out here and made
the move to this really expensive
beautiful very expensive city I don't
really do anything
film oriented happens to a lot of people
you have to will yourself to do and
obviously you should love doing it also
but just like anything else it can be
hard work may not be in the mood to do
film stuff every day
sometimes I'm not but if it's not every
day you should continually feel yourself
being pushed along you know be one of
them be that guy who like throws the
pencils of the ceilings that when you
look up there's no that says keep
working you should be working like no
kind of thing like stay on it's just
like anything else when you wrote escape
room and before you sold it were you in
a place where you're like this train
isn't moving fast enough I need to do
something or we're so driven because of
like going to escape room and then
you're like okay let me try to write one
for them I wasn't any panicked situation
over the years I quietly resign myself
to at least the possibility that I'll
never get a feature made I had so many
of my scripts option but not financed
that I was like okay I might just be
making my short films for dream seekers
forever and I came to peace with it I
was like as long as I get to tell
stories and produce films and direct
films I'll be okay it doesn't mean I
gave up on trying to to achieve my goals
but I came to peace with it but
certainly I think is I started to get
older I said I gotta make some moves
here I can't just keep doing what I've
been doing I got to do something and I
got
happen so I kind of gave myself a
deadline I said I'm getting the future
done this year
not necessarily directing it but I'm
going to sell a script over rights on
the script this year and I shifted up my
strategy my strategy became what do they
want I can't just write for me what do
they want and I pretty much had an idea
through enough meetings but what I
didn't know I just looked up again it's
keep your finger on the pulse of what
producers are asking for we like your
stuff but what we're looking for this
year is IP driven content or whatever it
is and I've been in enough meetings
where in this case horror I said this is
what we want you know and if you don't
have access to those producers look at
all the hit movies what are they all
have a comfortable you know when you
find the common denominators and do what
you got to do for me that's what I do I
said this script may not be like genre
redefining it may not be the script on
most probably I put a lot of myself in
it I made a story that I'm happy with
but this is definitely not a passion
project
I wrote this to be sold this is a
business decision and I wrote it and I
saw and I learned from that not
necessarily that I'm gonna throw all my
chips in that basket this is just
business now because it's film I love it
and it's a passion to me and it's
creative fulfilling so I'm not just in
it for business what it has taught me
though is to stay proactive as always
but to walk that line you know you can
always if you're a millionaire you'll
make your own passion projects and do it
however you want but if you want to go
out and get other people's money you got
to give them a little of what they're
looking for so the challenge becomes to
tell really cool creative interesting
stories within a framework that's gonna
work for other people and I think that's
a good place to start me was a place for
me and we'll see where it takes me you
had talked about writing overnight I was
wondering if you could just take me
through that process like what's it like
when do you start
is it like midnight and where are you
and are you playing music and what are
you doing to get yourself in that
headspace and when you stop I learned a
long time ago to write wherever and
whenever
could sometimes there's music on movie
soundtracks or whatever type of story
I'm writing to kind of get me going
sometimes the kids are sleeping music
goes off I got to write in silence
sometimes it's sitting in a car
sometimes it's at the airport it's
wherever I can not everyone's in my boat
with me I've got a busy family life
which I love to death but in terms of my
writing it's it would often be when the
kids are asleep and I've gotten house
chores done I'm trained so sometimes it
sounds great yeah you know so there you
are it's like I've worked all day yeah I
come home I handle the kids and and
there's family time and you play with
your kids make sure to give them the
time they need and before you know what
it's ten o'clock and you're exhausted
you gotta get up at 6:00 a.m. the next
morning but you got to do your thumb
stuff you got to stay proactive as we
said so it might be 10 11 o'clock you
sit down and you start writing you find
a quiet corner right I have a Sat home
that I work from that has become my
daughter's room so know I write kind of
anywhere else I can the kitchen table
but yeah you know sometimes I'll have
music if I'm lucky all the times I'll
keep it quiet or just a little solitary
lamp and you sit there you know in a
perfect world I have all the stuff I
needed seven know where to put it right
now I've got my movie posters from the
child for my childhood I've got like
I've got a necklace with the what is it
the Oran from neverending story I've got
all these things that inspire me you
know pirate stuff and Indiana Jones
stuff and Lord knows what all ready to
go up in an office so I can sit in the
midst of it and just be purely inspired
and just go right now I don't have room
for it so I basically sit in you know my
kitchen with like my blank like beige
walls and I just nothing inspiring there
whatsoever and I just got to rely on
what's in here I'll let the inspiration
bubble up from inside and it's fine you
know you go to bed at 2:00 or 3:00 in
the morning it's not gonna kill you let
me know as they say I'll sleep when I'm
dead I guess you know but you know and
the goal ultimately I think
like with mini FileMaker is when I have
some of my projects coming up that I'm
hoping or game-changers it becomes
something I can do full-time and then I
write during the day and I can sleep at
night but until then you know this is
just this is just what you do but I've
been doing it for years and I adapted to
it a long time ago
you